>>> WEEK 14 NFL BETS WE LOVE.
MY NAME IS GREG ARBY.
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN, THE MYTH,
SAM RICHMOND.
NEXT TO HIM IS THE MAN THAT'S
UNDEFEATED.
YOU'RE UNDEFEATED PRODUCER
RYAN.
I MEAN YOU CAME ON HERE BEFORE
THE SHOW.
YOU CAME ON HERE TALKING.
TALKING AND TALKING.
I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW, I'M
UNDEFEATED.
SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS, AND GO
AHEAD, TAKE IT AWAY, YOU'RE
UNDEFEATED, BRO.
>> WE HAVE SOME RY HEADS IN THE
CHAT WHO LET ME KNOW HEY, YOU
MADE ME SO MUCH MONEY, I'M SO
RICH BECAUSE OF YOU.
ARE YOU ALLERGIC TO LOSING?
I AM ALLERGIC TO LOSING.
IT'S NOT HEALTHY FOR ME.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW LAST
WEEK THAT BROWNS GAME.
THEY FUMBLE SIX, THEY PICK SIX,
PUNT RETURN, TOUCHDOWNS.
THOSE ARE THE THREE TOUCHDOWNS
THEY SCORED.
WE HAVE THE TEAM TOTAL UNDER
27.5.
ONE BY THE HOOK.
SO IF I LOST ON THOSE THREE
TOUCHDOWNS, I DON'T KNOW IF I
WOULD HAVE SHOWED UP TODAY.
BUT AGAIN, WE CANNOT LOSE RIGHT
NOW, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
>> I'M OVER HERE SPEECHLESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY, BRO.
YOU WON BY THE HOOK.
YOU TOOK THE BROWNS UNDER 27.5?
>> UNDER 27.5, YES.
>> AND THEY SCORED 27 POINTS?
>> 27 POINTS.
>> ON THREE NON-OFFENSIVE
TOUCHDOWNS AND YOU WON BY THE
HOOF.
YOU CAN'T BE HOTTER THAN THAT.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW THOUGH,
EVERYBODY.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE EVERYBODY
AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE NEW PEOPLE
YOU JUST LOGGED ON TO THE SHOW.
I'M HERE WITH THE MAN, THE MYTH,
THE LEGEND, SAM RICHMOND.
THE MAN NEXT TO HIM THAT'S 4-0,
RYAN PRODUCER.
WE ARE GIVING AWAY THE BEST BETS
FOR TODAY.
DROP YOUR CHATS, WE'LL BE
GRADING YOUR PICKS.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE NEED YOUR HELP
TO BUILD ANY TOUCHDOWN PARLAY.
>> WE NEED YOUR TOUCHDOWN
LOCKS.
AND WE NEED A PLUS 4,000.
SO WE ARE ALREADY ON TRACK.
WHAT YOU LIKE AND WE ARE GOING
TO BUILD THREE LEGS AND THEN BET
IT AND RIDE AS A FAMILY.
SO IT'S BEEN A FEW WEEKS.
I KNOW YOU GUYS WILL BE LIKE OH,
WE HAVEN'T HIT IN A FEW WEEKS,
WE NEED IT TO BE SAFE, BUT NO,
WE NEED TO GET RICH.
SO DROP WHAT YOU LIKE.
I ALREADY SEE THEM SAYING TONY
POLLARD, GUYS, YOU SAID THAT
EARLIER, BRO.
>> I DID SAY IT EARLIER.
>> AND BRIAN IS PAYING
COMMENTATORS TO PICK THAT.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
>> GO AHEAD, SORRY.
>> AND NO, GO AHEAD.
THAT WAS GOING ON, I'M JUST
CONCURRING WITH SAM THAT IT
MIGHT BE COMMENTS TO RIDE WITH
YOUR PICKS.
>> I'M REACHING OUT IN THE
BLEACHER REPORT SAYING HEY, I
NEED YOU TO DROP THAT.
THE TIGHT ENDS TO COME.
>> THE TIGHT ENDS TO COME.
TO BE HONEST, WHAT IS THAT?
MINUS 120?
>> THAT'S A LEG.
>> I MEAN ASK THE AUDIENCE.
LET'S ASK THE PEOPLE THOUGH.
LET'S ASK THEM.
IF YOU WANT TONY POLLARD THUMBS
UP, THUMB DOWN IN THE COMMENTS.
I LIKE THAT THOUGH, RYAN.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
LIKE WHY DO YOU THINK?
YOU NEED TO WIN US OVER, BRO.
THEY'RE PLAYING THE TEXANS,
WE KNOW THAT.
BUT YOU THINK TONY IS GETTING IN
TODAY?
>> I SEE THEM WHO SAYS POLLARD
HAS BEEN FLAT.
I PREFER TO SEE IT.
I DISAGREE ON THAT THEY'VE BEEN
FLAT.
THE THING WITH POLLARD, THE
COWBOYS ARE GOING TO SCORE A
RIDICULOUS AMOUNT OF POINT
TODAY.
THEY MIGHT BE THE FIRST TODAY
AGAINST THE HOUSTON TEXANS.
IT MIGHT HAPPEN.
BUT HE CAN DO THINGS IN THE
PASSING GAME THAT ZEKE CANNOT.
HAVING THAT FLEXIBILITY WITH
YOUR RUNNING BACK WHO WILL GET A
LOT OF CARRIES IS HUGE.
AND THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR IN ANY TIME THEY PLAY.
IF YOU'RE GOING WITH ZEKE, YOU
KIND OF NEED THE COWBOYS TO FALL
AROUND THE GOAL LINE.
I'M NOT NECESSARILY SURE THAT'LL
HAPPEN TODAY.
>> AND THAT IS OPPOSITE OF
THAT.
I WANT THAT GOAL LINE BACK OVER
THE GUY THAT YOU NEED THAT 20
YARD SPLASH PLAY.
YOU'LL GET 12, 15 CARRIES AND
YOU NEED ONE OF THOSE TO BREAK.
IT'S JUST TOUGH.
IT'S TOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> I WILL ALSO SAY THOUGH AS A
CALL BACK TO HOW I FEEL ABOUT
THE NEW YORK GIANTS.
THE HOUSTON TEXANS RUN DEFENSE
IS STINKY POO.
LIKE THEY'RE POP.
>> AND THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING,
ZEKE.
I'M GOING ZEKE THERE, YOU KNOW?
>> I'M GOING FOR THE ONE WITH
BETTER VALUE, SORRY.
GO AHEAD.
>> I HEAR YOU GUYS, THE CHAT.
I JUST WANTED TO JUMP IN HERE
AND SAY THE CHAT.
I DID SEE A LOT OF THUMBS UP ON
TONY POLLARD.
YOU GUYS ARE FILLING IT.
KEEP ON PUTTING THE THUMBS UP.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE CHAT.
I SEE A LOT OF THUMBS UP FOR MY
MAN.
SAM, I LOVE ZEKE TOO.
BUT THE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW?
>> I MEAN WE NEED TO GET UP HERE
AND THE THUMBS UP AND THUMBS
DOWN ARE COMING UP.
>> AND PHILLIPS SAYS POLLARD IS
A LOCK.
WE HAVE A GOOD STAT HERE FROM
BAGEL AND LOCKS WHO SAYS HERE IS
A FUN STAT THING.
ONLY TWO TEXANS PLAYERS HAVE
SHORTER ODDS THAN THE COWBOYS
DEFENSE.
LIKE I SAID, GUYS.
THAT'S INSANE.
>> AND ZEKE IS STARTING TO POP
IN THE CHAT.
>> LOOK, I DO SEE ZEKE, SAM.
I DO SEE ZEKE.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
>> YEAH, OKAY, THERE IS A LOT OF
ZEKE LOVE.
LISTEN, IF WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS, WE WILL START OFF WITH
ZEKE.
YOU GUYS COOL WITH THAT?
>> WOW.
THAT'S GOOD VIBES.
AND RYAN USUALLY DOESN'T CONCEDE
THIS EARLY.
THAT MAKES IT FEEL GOOD.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE TWO AND THREE
ARE GOING TO BE CRAZY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU'RE JUST SETTING ME UP
HERE.
YOU'RE SETTING ME UP.
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S DO IT.
WE ADDED ZEKE.
>> OKAY.
SO WE NEED WILLIAMS AND DERRICK
HENRY.
>> I WAS JUST ABOUT TO READ THAT
LAST WEEK.
THIS WEEK, MY NAME.
>> THAT WAS ALL THE CHAT.
JUST PUSHING DERRICK HENRY.
I WAS LIKE ALL RIGHT, FINE, WE
CAN DO DERRICK HENRY.
>> THE DIRECT QUOTE PEOPLE ARE
PASSING AROUND ARE CAN I OFFER A
BORING ONE?
THEN HE SAID DERRICK HENRY,
THAT'S NOT ALL TRUE.
IT'S ALL THE CHAT.
>> OF COURSE.
>> OKAY.
I SAW SOMEBODY --
>>
TROUBLE SINCE 1983 SAYS WHY NOT
BOTH?
NOW I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR
THIS.
WE JUST HAVE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
SO WHY NOT BOTH?
THAT'S NOT A BAD TAKE.
>> IT'S NOT A BAD TAKE.
IT IS JUST MY TAKE IS LIKE IF
THE COWBOYS START POURING IT ON,
THE STARTERS ARE GOING TO SIT.
SO YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
RELY ON -- I DON'T THINK YOU
WANT TO HAVE TO RELY ON TWO
COWBOYS HERE.
ONE IS FINE.
>> A LOT OF JAMAAL WILLIAMS
LOVING THE CHAT.
>> I WAS JUST ABOUT TO SAY
THAT.
>> I'M SORRY, GREG.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU'RE GOOD.
A LOT OF JAMAAL WILLIAMS IN THE
CHAT.
THEY SAY WILLIAMS, JEFFREY
ADAMS, AND JAMAL T.D.
WILLIAMS.
WE HAVE TO GO LOOK AT IT RIGHT.
>> I SEE THAT.
AND THAT THERE IS A LOT OF LOVE
FOR THAT GAME.
>> I MOVED PAST THAT.
I'M READING THE COMMENTS AS HE
RETURNS TO DETROIT AND THE TEAM
THAT TRADED HIM IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE SEASON AND HE IS PLUS 190 TO
SCORE THE TOUCHDOWN.
I MEAN HOW MANY TARGETS DID HE
GET?
>> PROBABLY A TARGET GUY.
>> PROBABLY SO MANY.
I ACTUALLY DO NOT HATE
HOPKINSON.
TO YOUR POINT, RYAN, THEY WILL
PROBABLY WANT TO GET HIM A
TOUCHDOWN AGAINST HIS FORMER
TEAM AND IF THEY ARE IN THE RED
ZONE, I COULD SEE THAT
HAPPENING.
>> THERE WILL BE A TON OF POINTS
TOO.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY COULD DO
THAT THOUGH.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> DO YOU THINK THEY WANT TO
GIVE HIM A TOUCHDOWN, SO THEY
WILL FEED HIM AGAINST THE LIONS
DEFENSE.
DO YOU THINK THEY WILL CALL WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO?
>> THIS IS FOR GREG TO
TRANSITION AND JUSTIN JEFFERSON,
WHICH I'M ALL FOR.
>> NO, NO, NO.
NO, NO, NO.
HE'S NOT PLUS MONEY RIGHT
HERE, SAM.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> THAT'S TRUE.
HE GOT SIX TARGETS LAST WEEK.
HE HAD 4-43.
SO IT'S NOT WHAT YOU WOULD LOVE
TO SEE.
DO YOU LIKE TO SEE IT?
IT IS PLUS 190 AGAINST HIS
FORMER TEAM.
THIS JUST FEELS --
>>
WHERE IS JAMAAL WILLIAMS?
>> HE'S RIGHT THERE MINUS 120.
>> THAT'S NOT BAD.
>> THE PEOPLE WANT JAMAAL
WILLIAMS.
>> I DO?
>> THUMBS UP, THUMBS DOWN FOR
JAMAAL WILLIAMS.
I LIKE WHEN THE CHAT GETS
FLUTTERED WITH THUMBS UP, THUMBS
DOWN.
>> I NEED TO READ SOME CHATS
HERE AND I LIKE T.J.
FOR TWO
TDs OR MORE REVENGE GAMES.
AND SPACE 46.
HAWKINSON PROBABLY THE FIRST
TD.
S RILEY SAYS I WANT THE STATS ON
REVENGE GAME.
COME ON.
>> YOU'RE DELIBERATELY.
HEY, HE'S DELIBERATELY GOING TO
ALL THE COMMENTS AND READING
THEM UP.
BECAUSE LITERALLY I'M SEEING
WILLIAMS LOCK.
>> I SEE WILLIAMS.
AND THAT HAS WILLIAMS LOCKED.
>> TRAVIS KELCE, ADAM THIELEN.
>> I SAW ADAM THIELEN.
BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT ADAM
THIELEN.
I THOUGHT WE WERE
BETWEEN JAMAAL WILLIAMS AND --
>>
THEY WANT JAY.
>> YES.
>> OKAY, HOW ABOUT THIS.
YOU GUYS TELL US JAMAAL WILLIAMS
OR T.J.
HAWKINSON.
THAT'LL BE THE PLAY WE MAKE.
WRITE THEIR NAMES DOWN.
NO THUMBS UP OR THUMBS DOWN, JAY
WILL OR HAWK.
>> WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANOTHER LEG
>> I MEAN I SEE HOCK.
I SAW HOCK.
HOLD ON, LET ME READ IT.
THEY SAY HOCK
LOCK.
>> THE LAST SEVEN COMMENTS ARE
WILLIAMS, WILLIAMS, WILLIAMS.
>> A LOT OF WILLIAMS IN THERE,
BRIAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
A LOT OF JAMAAL WILLIAMS IN
THERE.
SORRY, BRO.
>> THAT'S TWO.
>> GUYS.
>> IT HAD IS JUICY.
THAT'S PLUS MONEY, BABY.
THAT'S ALL WE LOOK FOR.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
WHAT'S NEXT?
>> THROW ANOTHER JUICY ONE OUT
THERE, MINUS 215.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT YOU KNOW THAT'LL BE THE
CHAT, TAKE IT.
>> HEY RYAN, HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
I GOT A REAL GOOD
TAKE FOR YOU.
BAGEL AND LOX IS IN THE COMMENT
SAYING DONOVAN KNIGHT.
>> HE'S PROBABLY MINUS 250.
NO, HE'S PLUS 215.
SORRY.
>> THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S UP YOUR
ALLEY, RYAN.
>> YES, BUT IT'S AGAINST THE
BILLS AND IT WILL BE SO COLD IN
BUFFALO.
>> RYAN ONLY WANTS THE JUICY ONE
IF HE ORIGINATES IT.
HE WANTS THE CREDIT.
HE WANTS THE GLORY OF I SOUGHT
THE JUICY ONE.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I'M JUST TRYING TO THINK SUB 30
DEGREES IN BUFFALO.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> HE HAD 15 CARRIES LAST WEEK.
>> HEY, HEY ACTUALLY HOLD ON,
THAT'S NOT BAD.
>> AND NOW WHAT DOES THE CHAT
THINK OF DONOVAN?
>> AND JUST THE AMOUNT OF WHAT
I'M SEEING NOT TO GO BACK.
BUT YOU WOULD PAY THOSE PEOPLE.
SO LET'S MOVE ON.
>> WE GOT A SHOUT OUT FOR NUMBER
TWO WHO SAID THIS IS MY WEEKLY
SUNDAY MORNING COMEDY SHOW AS WE
APPRECIATE THE LOVE.
>> WE LOVE THAT.
YOU LOVE SENDING PEOPLE SOCKS.
>> WE'VE GOT A BOAT LOAD OF
SOCKS.
>> WE HAVE TOO MANY SOCKS.
>> I NEED SOME OF THOSE SOCKS.
THEY'RE FRESH.
THOSE SOCKS ARE FRESH.
GUYS, GUYS.
ALL RIGHT, SO ARE
WE ASKING THE AUDIENCE AND
LOCKING IN DONOVAN KNIGHT?
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
>> AND SOMEONE THREW OUT AN
INTERESTING ONE.
STEPHEN DIGGS, NOT STEFON DIGGS,
BUT STEPHEN DIGGS.
>> I DIDN'T SEE IT.
>> WHEN THIS HITS, GUYS, IT'S
PROBABLY RIGHT HERE.
>> WHY DID WE MOVE ON DONOVAN?
I FEEL LIKE WE WERE RIGHT THERE
AND THEN JUST LEFT.
>> BOSTON SCOTT.
>> AND LOOK AT THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE ALL SAYING
HELL NO.
>> TO WHAT?
TO DONOVAN?
>> I THINK TO DONOVAN.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE NEED ANOTHER
TAKE TO DISCUSS.
SOMEBODY SAID BOSTON SCOTT IS
CRAZY VERSES THE GIANTS, WOW.
HEY RYAN, LET'S JUST LOOK AT
THIS ONE.
I SAW HOPKINS IN THE COMMENTS.
SOMEBODY COMMENTED HOPKINS.
WHAT'S THE NUMBERS?
>> WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL MONDAY
NIGHT TO CASH THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO WAIT.
>> IT MIGHT NOT BE WORTH IT, BUT
WE'RE MEN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, WE ARE MEN OF THE
PEOPLE.
>> PLUS 115.
>> PLUS 515.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S AN
INTERESTING ONE OR AN
INTERESTING POTENTIAL?
WE GO SUNDAY NIGHT GAME.
WE TRY TO CREATE THE LAST LEG
SITCH.
AGAINST POVERTY DOLPHINS
DEFENSE.
>> I TOLD YOU GUYS ABOUT THAT
LAST WEEK.
I TOLD YOU GUYS ABOUT
KEENAN ALLEN LAST WEEK.
>> GUYS, CAN WE PICK THE
RECEIVERS THAT ARE GOING TO
FINISH THE GAME?
>> HE DIDN'T FINISH.
>> HE FINISHED THE GAME LAST
WEEK.
>> MIKE WILLIAMS, NOT EVEN ON
THE INJURY REPORT.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> FOREVER SAYING MARK ANDREWS
AS WE WOULD TALK ABOUT THIS
BEFORE THE SHOW.
HE'LL GO OFF OF TYLER HUNTLEY AS
HIS QUARTERBACK.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, WE DID
TALK ABOUT THAT.
>> THOSE NUMBERS, THEY WERE
BEAUTIFUL, WERE THEY NOT?
>> IT IS RISKY THOUGH.
MY MAN KEENAN
ALLEN WENT FOR 6-88 LAST WEEK,
AVERAGE 14 YARDS PER CATCH,
BALLER.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF LOVE.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE ON OUR
SIDE MENTIONED, BUT OUT OF
NOWHERE, JUST LIKE TYLER.
>> HE'S BEEN SCORING.
AND LOCKETT.
LET'S SEE WHAT
IT'S LOOKING LIKE.
>> YES, LOCKETT, ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT.
AND YOU'RE OUT OF THIS GROSS
MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL GAME.
WHERE ARE THE SEAHAWKS RIGHT
NOW?
>> TYLER LOCKETT.
>> I PLAYED HIM IN FANTASY THE
OTHER DAY.
>> I MEAN THE CHAT LIKES TYLER
LOCKETT.
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
LET'S ASK THE CHAT.
CHAT, YOU GUYS ARE ROCKING WITH
TYLER LOCKETT.
WE NEED A LOT OF THUMBS UP.
NEED A LOT OF THUMBS UP IN THE
CHAT IF YOU'RE ROCKING WITH
TYLER LOCKETT.
IF YOU'RE NOT, THUMBS DOWN.
PLUS 145.
THEY'RE TAKING ON THE CAROLINA
PANTHERS IN SEATTLE, FELLAS.
THIS GAME IS
HAPPENING IN SEATTLE.
RYAN, LOOK AT YOUR FACE.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GET OVER
T.J.
HOCKENSON.
I WON'T LIE.
>> THAT'S WHERE YOU MAKE THE
RYAN SPECIAL PARLAY.
IT'S TONY POLLARD, HOCKENSON,
AND WHATEVER OTHER TIGHT END YOU
WANT TO THROW.
>> YES, IT'S MARK ANDREWS, YES.
>> THAT'S THE RYAN SPECIAL AND
THIS IS OUR PARLAY.
>> OKAY.
>> YEAH, I MEAN LISTEN, I LOVE
TYLER LOCKETT.
HE SCORES A LOT.
YEAH, DO WE WANT -- ALL RIGHT,
WE WILL GO THUMBS UP, THUMBS
DOWN.
>> THAT IS A LOT OF THUMBS UP.
>> YEAH, THAT'S FIVE THUMBS UP.
THAT'S A FIVE STAR REVIEW RIGHT
THERE WITH VAPOR MAN AND ALMOST
TEN IT THUMBS UP.
FOR THUMBS
UP AND JACKSON WITH THREE THUMBS
UP.
FOUR THUMBS
DOWN.
PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY WANT THE
RYAN SPECIAL.
TRUST ME, I'M WITH YOU GUYS.
>> WE'VE GOT TO STICK TO THE
PLAN.
>> THAT'S THE RYAN SPECIAL.
IT WON'T GIVE UP THE RYAN
SPECIAL AT THE END.
>> YES, WE'LL TWEET IT.
WE'LL BE GOOD, GUYS.
WE'LL WIN BOTH.
TWIN NUMBER TWO
SAYS HE IS CHALK FULL OF HOCK.
THAT'S TRUE.
A TON OF THUMBS.
ALL RIGHT, THERE IS LOVE FOR
THIS.
LET'S LOCK THIS IN.
>> LET'S LOCK IT IN.
WE'RE GOING TO LOCK THIS ONE
IN.
AND FOR ONE MORE
TIME ONE MORE TIME, READ IT FOR
US AND THE NEW PEOPLE WHO JUST
JOINED THE SHOW.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE RIDING WITH.
>> I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS, I
DO.
SO IT'S ZEKE MINUS 150 FOR THE
FIRST LEG.
JAMAAL WILLIAMS NOT T.J.
HOCKENSON, MINUS 120 FOR THE
SECOND LEG.
TYLER LOCKETT IS OUR THIRD LEG
AT PLUS 145.
YOU COOK THAT ALL TOGETHER.
IT'S A THREE LEG PARLAY.
THAT ADDS UP TO PLUS 648.
IT'S A LOCK AND IT'S HITTING.
WE'LL BE BACK THIS WEEK.
WE'RE BACK ON THE WINNING SIDE
OF THIS AND WE WILL SPEAK IT
INTO EXISTENCE.
MAKE SURE YOU TAIL IT ON
DRAFTKINGS.
IT WOULDN'T BE SUNDAY IF I
DIDN'T DO A LITTLE TV BOOST
MAGIC.
SO WE ARE ALSO GOING TO BOOST
DALVIN COOK ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
FROM MINUS 145 TO PLUS 100.
THERE IT IS.
WE'LL BOOST IT FOR YOU AND YOU
CAN SEE IT RIGHT THERE ON YOUR
SCREEN.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME FOR MY MAN
SAM, SIX BEST BETS.
SAM, YOU BROUGHT US SIX BETS.
WE'RE SENDING HIM TO THE CHAT.
AND LET'S START OFF WITH YOUR
FIRST PICK.
CAN WE PLEASE GET 45 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK?
SAM, WE'RE GOING
TO GET RIGHT TO IT AND WASTE NO
TIME.
WE'RE COUNTING HOW MANY TIMES
YOU SAY THAT.
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
LET'S GO.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE'RE STARTING OFF
HOT AND STARTING OFF
CONTROVERSIAL.
YOU'RE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS
TOO, SO IT SHOULD BE
INTERESTING.
MY FAVORITE PICK OF THE DAY IS
LIONS MONEY LINE AT MINUS 130.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE REALLY
SURPRISED WHEN THE LIONS CAME
OUT AND THEY WERE FAVORED.
BUT TO ME, I'M SORRY, THE
VIKINGS ARE THE LUCKIEST TEAM
THAT WE'VE EVER SEEN, JUST
HISTORICALLY LUCKY.
HE HAS A TWEET THAT HE WILL
BRING UP AFTER I'M DONE.
BUT THEY'RE 20th AND IT WAS A
SPOT BELOW THE ATLANTA FALCONS.
THEY'RE CONSISTENTLY WAITING
GAMES THEY SHOULDN'T WIN.
MEANWHILE THE LIONS ARE PLAYING
REALLY GOOD FOOTBALL.
THEY'RE AT HOME IN THE DOME AND
THEIR DEFENSE HAS REALLY
IMPROVED.
I REALLY LIKE THEM TODAY.
THEY FINALLY END THIS VIKINGS
LUCK.
>> SAM LIKES THE LIONS, I DO
NOT, BUT THAT'S OKAY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHAT I LIKE, IT'S
NOT ABOUT WHAT SAM LIKES.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU GUYS LIKE.
YOU'RE THE PEOPLE.
LET'S TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
THERE HE IS, PRODUCER RYAN.
WHAT'S THE CHAT TALKING ABOUT?
>> WELL FIRST, SAM, I'LL GIVE
YOU MY VENMO AFTER THE SHOW.
>> OF COURSE.
>> YEAH, COOL.
BUT WE PULLED UP THIS TWEET TO
BACK UP YOUR PROPAGANDA AS THEY
WILL GO FROM THE FIRST TEAM EVER
WITH NEGATIVE DBOA TO THE FIRST
TEAM EVER WITH THE NEGATIVE DBOA
AT 10-2.
THE VIKINGS WERE THE ONLY 10-2
TEAM WITHIN 15 PERCENTAGE POINTS
WITH THEM.
>> AND THEY ARE HISTORICALLY
LUCKY.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN A TEAM THIS
BAD.
BUT THE POINT IS WE'VE NEVER
SEEN A TEAM THIS BAD BE AT 10-2
AND IT IS COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE AND THAT'S IT, I'M
DONE.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT THE CHAT.
THE LIONS IS A LOCK AND DROPPED
NOT ONE, BUT TWO LOCK EMOJIS.
WHAT'S UP.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> HOLD ON, DO YOU HAVE PEOPLE
MAKING FAKE PAGES, BRO?
I SEE A PRODUCER RYAN IN THE
COMMENTS.
>> NO, THAT'S ME.
OH, OKAY I'M SORRY.
I THOUGHT RYAN HAD PEOPLE MAKING
FAKE PAGES.
KEEP GOING, BRO.
>> ALL GOOD.
KR5 SAYS THIS GUY GOES AGAINST
THE VIKINGS EVERY WEEK.
YES, YOU DO.
>> I DO.
I DO.
AND THEY'VE BEATEN ME, LIKE
HANDS UP.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S
SUSTAINABLE.
I DID GET THEM ONE WEEK WHEN THE
COWBOYS BEAT THEM BY 75 POINTS.
>> YES.
YES.
GOOD TIMES.
I LIKE DETROIT.
JUSTIN CULBREATH.
JEFFREY ADAMS LIONS WITH THE
THUMBS UP EMOJI.
>> THEY MUST BE THE AMERICAN
TEAM.
BREATH SAM, TAKE IT AWAY
AND I THINK IT'S AT FOUR RIGHT
NOW AS THEY CONFIRMED MAYBE
LOWER.
I STILL LIKE IT AT FOUR.
BUT TO ME THAT IS JUST A REALLY
BAD SITUATIONAL SPOT FOR THE
BENGALS.
I LIKE THIS TEAM A LOT, BUT
AGAIN IT'S A REAL TOUGH SPOT FOR
THEM COMING OFF A MONSTER WIN
AND THAT IS HOW GOOD THEY ARE
AND ALL THAT STUFF AND HAVING TO
PLAY THAT DIVISIONAL OPPONENT
WITH THAT MANY POINTS IS JUST
TOO MUCH, THEY'RE PLAYING WELL
AND THEY HAVE ANOTHER WEEK TO
GET ACCLIMATED WITH THE
QUARTERBACK SWITCH, SO I LIKE
THEM HERE.
YOU GET A LITTLE VALUE BASED ON
THE LINE BECAUSE I THINK
ORIGINALLY, I GUESS NOW IT'S
BACK DOWN TO FOUR.
BUT AT FIVE AND A HALF THAT LINE
WAS INFLATED AFTER THE BIG WIN.
>> AND DO YOU HAVE ANY OPTIMISM
OR ARE YOU SKEPTICAL AT ALL
AFTER SEEING THAT OFFENSE FROM
CLEVELAND LAST WEEK?
>> IT WASN'T GOOD.
I KNOW, RYAN TOUCHED ON IT,
THEIR POINTS WERE UP.
SPECIAL TEAMS AND DEFENSE.
BUT I THINK YOU GET ANOTHER
WEEK, AGAIN, ACCLIMATED WITH THE
QUARTERBACK CHANGE AND I LIKE
THEM TO JUST THROW THAT GAME
DOWN WITH CHUBB.
IT'S WHAT THEY DO, WHICH BODES
WELL FOR THE UNDERDOG.
SO I DO STILL LIKE THE BROWNS
EVEN THOUGH YEAH, THEY DID NOT
LOOK GREAT OFFENSIVELY.
>> I DO WANT TO SAY THIS.
MY MAN RYAN GAVE US THE SCOOP
BEFORE THE SHOW SAYING THE
BENGALS WILL NOT PLAY WELL.
SAM MIGHT BE ON
TO SOMETHING.
HE MIGHT BE ON TO SOMETHING.
TWO DOWN, FOUR MORE TO GO.
45 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK,
PLEASE.
THERE IT IS, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, THE NEXT ONE IS
VERY SCARY.
JUST FOR ME PERSONALLY BECAUSE
THE NEXT TIME I WIN A BET ON A
GAME INVOLVING THE TENNESSEE
TITANS WILL BE THE FIRST ONE.
BECAUSE THIS TEAM JUST KILLS ME
WHEN I BET ON THEM, THEY GET
SMOKED.
WHEN I BET AGAINST THEM, THEY
LOSE.
I LIKE THEM AT PLUS 3.5.
THE TITANS ARE JUST A POSSESS
RIGHT NOW.
THEY CAN'T RUN THE BALL.
THEY'VE BEEN TOTALLY STOPPED ON
THE GROUND NOW DOWN TO 20th
AND IN RUSH OFFENSE DBOA, WHICH
REALLY MATTERS A LOT WHEN YOUR
QUARTERBACK IS RYAN TANNEHILL
WHO IS KIND OF HOBBLING AND YOU
HAVE NO OFFENSIVE WEAPONS.
LIKE THEY JUST REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING GOING FOR THEM.
FOR ME THIS IS MORE OF A TOTAL
FATE OF THE TITANS THAN A PLAY
ON THE JAGS AND AFTER THEY GOT
SMOKED LAST WEEK.
BUT THEY'RE ON MY
LIST AGAIN.
I'M TOTALLY OUT ON THEM.
>> TITANS ARE ON SAM'S LIST, SO
HE'S ROCKING JACKSONVILLE PLUS
3.5.
THAT'S THREE PICKS THAT YOU GOT
WE WILL BRING HIM IN HERE IN A
MINUTE, BUT SAM, WE'VE GOT THREE
PICKS TO GO.
45 SECONDS ON THE PICK, PLEASE.
>> MY NEXT PICK IS PANTHERS PLUS
4.
ANOTHER GROSS ONE THAT I'M SURE
THEY WILL HATE.
BUT LOOK, I BET ON THE SEAHAWKS
TEAM A LOT TO START THE YEAR.
BUT TO ME, I'M STARTING TO GET
CONCERNED WITH THEM.
THEY HAD A FEW WEEKS IN A ROW
WHERE THEIR DEFENSE HAS LOOKED
SUSPECT, GIVING UP A MILLION
YARDS ON THE GROUND.
THEY LET JOHN WOFFORD ALMOST
BEAT THEM LAST WEEK.
THEY JUST HAVEN'T BEEN PLAYING
WELL.
CAROLINA'S DEFENSE HAS BEEN
AMAZING.
SO THEY'RE NOT TANKING THE
SEASON AWAY EVEN AT HOME.
>> YES, A FIELD GOAL GAME.
WOMANFORD -- THAT'S A TOUGH
WIN.
>> I LIKE THIS.
THAT'S FOUR, FOUR DOWN, TWO MORE
TO GO.
SAM, CAN WE GET 45 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK, PLEASE.
LET'S GO, SAM.
>> ALL RIGHT, IF I ALREADY
HAVEN'T LOST THAT CHAT, WHICH I
FEEL LIKE THE LAST FEW WEEKS
I'VE GOT THE CHAT ON MY SIDE AND
THIS WEEK, I JUST TOTALLY LOST
THAT, WHICH IS OKAY.
BUT THIS ONE IS GOING TO LOSE
THEM.
I'M TAKING THE DENVER BRONCOS
PLUS MINUS 9.5.
PLUS THIS IS AS GROSS AS IT
GETS.
I TOTALLY GET IT.
DON'T WATCH THE GAME.
BUT AT END OF THE GAME YOU'LL
LOOK UP AND SEE THAT BET CASHED
HERE.
THE BRONCOS DEFENSE IS STILL
PLAYING REALLY WELL.
THAT'S TOO MANY POINTS AT HOME
AND IN THAT DIVISIONAL GAME.
YOU GIVE ME A DEFENSE THAT IS
GENERALLY SPEAKING, ALLOWING 14
POINTS A WEEK.
LIKE I'M TAKING
10 POINTS.
OBVIOUSLY THEY WON'T HOLD THE
CHIEFS TO 14 POINTS.
ALL YOU REALLY NEED ARE TWO
TOUCHDOWNS FROM THE BRONCOS, BUT
THE CHIEFS DEFENSE IS 25th AND
THE DEFENSIVE DBOA.
THEY HAVE A REALLY BAD DEFENSE.
I PUT MY FAITH IN RUST THAT
HE'LL GET ME TWO TOUCHDOWNS AND
COVER THE NUMBER.
IT'S TOO MANY POINTS.
>> SAM IS PUTTING HIS FAITH IN
RUST, SO HE MIGHT NEED TO GET ON
HIS KNEES AND PRAY, BROTHER.
>> JUST GIVE ME TWO.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE CHAT?
LET'S BRING PRODUCER RYAN BACK
IN HERE BECAUSE MY MAN IS IN THE
CHAT TALKING TO HIMSELF I THINK
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE
PEOPLE, MY IDENTITY IS BEING
SOLD.
>> AND THERE IS SOMEBODY IN THAT
CHAT WITH NO FOLLOWERS, THE
PRODUCER.
THAT'S NOT ME.
I DIDN'T EVEN SEE TIME TO SEE
HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT IT.
>> YOU HAVE A CHECK MARK.
>> I DO HAVE A CHECK MARK.
I'M VERIFIED.
>> OH YEAH, HE'S VERIFIED.
YOU'RE VERIFIED ON THAT.
>> MY GOODNESS.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S
GET TO THE ACTUAL TAKES, WHERE I
WAS ON THE PHONE WITH THE FBI
DURING THAT.
IDENTITY THEFT IS
NOT A JOKE.
AND RUSS HAS MORE
TOILETS THAN THE PASSING
TOUCHDOWNS.
AND THAT MIGHT BE
SHROUDER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW BIG HIS HOUSE
IS.
HE LIKES THE OVER AND THE
VIKINGS AND THE LIONS GAME.
AND SPECCO LOVES
FOUR OUT OF FIVE, BUT DENVER
JUST CAN'T.
>> I GET THAT.
I TOTALLY GET THAT.
LIKE I ROAST THE BRONCOS PICK.
I GET IT, BUT I DO THINK THEY
WILL HIT.
>> YEAH.
LET'S SEE.
M. TAYLOR SAYS YOU'RE PICKING
SOME SUSPECT TEAMS TODAY.
THERE WAS
SOMEBODY WHO DIDN'T LIKE YOUR
BACKING OF THE PANTHERS.
I'M TRYING TO FIND WHO THAT
WAS.
I WOULD IMAGINE THEY DO NOT
ENJOY YOU?
>> YES.
I'M LOOKING AT THE CHAT.
NOT POSITIVE THAT WEEK.
I TAKE THAT IN.
I TRY TO DO MY BEST TO PUT FORTH
SOME WINNERS AND WE WILL SEE IT
NEXT WEEK IF THE CHAT WILL DO
THAT.
>> THAT IS HILARIOUS.
THEY HAVE A COUNTER AS THEY
WOULD SAY SAM, WE LOVE THAT AND
KEEP THEM COMING.
KEEP COUNTING.
APPARENTLY YOU SAID THAT FOUR
TIMES?
>> I'M PROUD OF MYSELF.
I'M GOOD WITH THAT.
>> THAT'S JUST TO FIVE, IT WENT
UP TO FIVE.
WE ARE TAKING BETS.
YOU CANNOT BE THERE.
THAT'S SUPER
FUNNY THAT WE'VE GOT THEM
COUNTING THAT AND I LOVE IT.
I LOVE IT.
GET BACK IN THERE WITH US.
>> WE'VE GOT SOME LATE LOVE FROM
DR. 87.
BOTH, THEY SAY PANTHERS WIN.
THEY SAY CAROLINA PLUS 4, LOVE
THEM BOTH.
JOE DEAN SAYS HE LOVES THE
DENVER PICK.
I PUT THEM IN MY PARLAY.
WHERE SHE SOME LOVE COMING IN
THERE THAT MAYBE WERE GROSS,
STINKY.
NASTY.
>> MY BAD, PRODUCER RYAN.
BUT SAM, YOU'RE GETTING SOME
LOVE IN THE COMMENTS.
THEY WANT TO KNOW YOUR TWITTER,
YOUR TWITTER HANDLE.
SO GIVE THEM YOUR TWITTER
HANDLE.
>> IT'S MY NAME AND WHERE I
WORK.
NO UNDERSCORE.
>> MAKE SURE YOU ALL TAP IN WITH
SAM AND SAM, ALSO, WE'VE GOT
DAD.
HE'S NEW TO THE SHOW AND HE SAID
HE WAS NEW TO THE SHOW AND HE
HOPES TO COME HERE TO GET SOME
UNBIAS PLAYS.
THANK YOU FOR TUNING IN.
BUT SAM, HE'S NEW TO BEDDING.
SO DAD, HE SAYS WHAT'S DBOA?
EXPLAIN IT TO HIM.
>> DBOA.
OBVIOUSLY A BUNCH OF ADVANCED
METRICS OUT THERE.
I THINK THEY DO THE BEST JOB OF
SORT OF COMBINING EVERYTHING
ABOUT FOOTBALL AND INTO JUST
VERY BASIC NUMBERS TO UNDERSTAND
IT IN THE RANKINGS.
BUT BASICALLY JUST ACCOUNTS FOR
EVERY SINGLE PLAY THAT'S
HAPPENING IS BEING GRANTED AND
LOOKED AT AND FACTORS IN THE
STRENGTH OF THE SCHEDULE AND
FACTORS IN THE LUCK AND ALL THAT
STUFF THE VIKINGS SUCK AT AND
THEY ARE SOMEHOW WINNING GAMES.
WHEN YOU GET OUTGAMED AND YOU
STILL WIN, YOUR DBO COULD DROP
EVEN THOUGH YOUR RECORD MIGHT
INCREASE.
IT IS JUST A GOOD ADVANCED
METRIC THAT INCAPSULATE
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS IN THE
GAME.
>> RYAN, THERE'S BREAKING NEWS.
SHE SAYS RYAN IS A LOSSER,
SPELLED WITH TWO S ISs,s.
>> LET'S SEND RYAN BACK TO THE
CHAT BECAUSE I STRONGLY FEEL
HE'S MAKE ALL THESE THINGS NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S UNFAIR?
YOU GUYS BET THE OVER ON LIVE
DBOA AND THEN READ A COMMENT
WHERE I HAD TO SAY IT FOUR
TIMES.
AND NOW THEY'VE GOT ME LIKE
EIGHT AND I PROBABLY SAID IT TWO
MORE TIMES IN THE OVERCAST.
YOU GUYS WIN.
>> ALL RIGHT, HEY, LET'S SEND
RYAN BACK TO THE CHAT.
RYAN, YOU'RE GOING TO COME BACK
HERE SOON.
45 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK.
SAM, WE'VE GOT FIVE PICKS.
WE NEED ONE MORE.
LET'S GET TO IT, BROTHER.
>> ALL RIGHT, THE LAST PICK PLUS
THREE AND A HALF AND THAT IS A
REAL GOOD BUY AND LOW SPOT WITH
THAT INFLATED LINE AS WE WOULD
TALK A LOT ABOUT THIS SHOW AND
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS WHEN THEY
HAVE THEIR FULL OFFENSIVE
WEAPON.
AND HE'S BAD, IT'S BEEN BELOW
AVERAGE ALL YEAR AND THEY WERE
LIT UP LAST WEEK AND NINERS ARE
REALLY GOOD, BUT THAT'S A PRETTY
BAD LOOK TO GET BEAT UP COMING
OFF THE BENCH.
THE BIGGEST HOLD THEY HAVE IS
THEIR RUSH DEFENSE AS THEY DON'T
REALLY RUN THAT BALL AND THEY
ARE CONFIDENT THROUGH THE PASS
DEFENSES.
JUST TOO MANY POINTS.
BUY LOW ON THE TEAM AND THAT
TYPE OF SPOT IN MY OPINION.
>> THERE IT IS, MY MAN, ROCKING
WITH THE CHARGERS.
I SEE S. RILEY 99.
BRO, HE'S BEEN RIDING WITH YOUR
PICKS THE WHOLE DAY, BUT SAYS HE
LIKES THE CHARGERS.
AND LET'S BRING THE PRODUCER
BACK IN HERE BECAUSE HE'LL TALK
ABOUT THE CHAT AND PROBABLY ALL
THE FAKE ACCOUNTS THAT HE'S
PAYING PEOPLE TO MAKE.
>> GUYS, THERE IS SO MANY
PRODUCER RYANS IN HERE.
>> AND THEY'RE CALLING OUT THE
OTHER TO STOP BEING FAKE AND I
HAVE LOST FULL CONTROL.
>> PRODUCER RYAN SAYS PRODUCER
RYANS UNITE.
>> I'M TRYING TO STAY UNITED IN
THE CHAT, MAN.
>> I TRIED TO FORCE A SUPER
TEAM.
BUT IT WON'T HAPPEN.
AND THEY ALL WANT TO BE THEIR
OWN PRODUCER RYAN.
I GET IT.
ALL RIGHT, THEY SAY YES, WITHOUT
A HEALTHY ARM STEAD, TUA WILL
STRUGGLE.
PRODUCER RYAN, RAW GUYS UNITE.
THERE IS JUST SO
MUCH TALK IN HERE RIGHT NOW WITH
THESE FAKE ACCOUNTS.
HE SAYS JAMES IS OUT.
DOES THAT CONCERN YOU, SAM?
>> IT DOES.
I MEAN I EXPECTED THAT.
SO NO, NOT SUPER CONCERNED.
AND I THINK ARM STEAD IS
GOING TO PLAY BUT I DO NOT LIKE
WHAT I'M SEEING.
I KNOW IT'S NOT THE PICK YOU
GAVE OUT.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
I JUST DON'T BET TOTAL.
THERE IS NO RHYME OR REASON
BEHIND IT.
THEY ARE MORE FUN TO ME.
>> THE TOTAL IN THAT GAME IS
55.
THAT'S AN ABSURD TOTAL LIKE A
COLLEGE FOOTBALL TOTAL.
JAMES OUT, HILL GOING
OUT.
I LIKE THE MONEY LINE.
SURPRISINGLY,
HAVE THE PEOPLE FALLEN OFF ON
THE DOLPHINS?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY ON THE
DOLPHINS, THEY PLAYED A GOOD
TEAM LAST WEEK, I'M JUST SAYING,
NO COMMENTS, NO BIAS THERE.
THEY'RE A GOOD TEAM, A REALLY
GOOD TEAM.
>> RYAN, ARE WE DONE WITH THE
CHAT, MAN?
SHOULD WE MOVE ON?
WHAT'S THE VIBES?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
IT'S TOO MUCH.
TOO MUCH FRAUD GOING ON IN THE
CHAT RIGHT NOW.
LET'S JUST MOVE ON.
>> TOO MUCH FRAUD GOING ON IN
THE CHAT.
TOO MUCH PRODUCER RYANS.
THEY'RE UNITING IN THE CHAT.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE IT.
LET'S MOVE ON.
YOU GUYS SEE IT COMING UP AT THE
TOP OF YOUR SCREEN WHERE IT SAYS
GREG'S PICKS?
YES, WE HEARD FROM SAM.
NOW I GOT A PICK FOR YOU, RYAN.
LET'S PULL UP DRAFTKINGS OR
ACTUALLY YOU ALREADY HAVE IT
PULLED UP.
LOOK GUYS, SAM,
RYAN, PEOPLE IN THE CHAT.
PEOPLE THAT ARE WATCHING.
WE HAVE A RULE HERE ON THIS
SHOW.
WE HAVE A RULE ON THE SHOW.
WHENEVER YOU SEE JUSTIN
JEFFERSON PLUS MONEY TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN, YOU TAKE IT.
TODAY, MY MAN JEFFERSON TO SCORE
A TOUCHDOWN WAS MINUS 140.
BUT I STARTED SCROLLING.
I STARTED SCROLLING ON
DRAFTKINGS, LOOKING TO FIND MY
MAN JUSTIN JEFFERSON WITH SOME
PLUS MONEY.
AND I FOUND SOMETHING.
AND THE VIKINGS
TO WIN.
CAN YOU PLEASE CLICK IT?
ALL THE METRICS
THAT HE'S TALKING AND THEY WILL
PROVE HIM WRONG TO GO GET A WIN
AND THEY WILL DO THAT TODAY AND
MY MAN IS GOING TO HELP THEM DO
THAT AGAINST THAT LIONS
DEFENSE.
I'M LOCKING THAT ONE IN.
>> I NEED A SIDE BET.
MAYBE THE CHAT COULD GIVE US
SUGGESTIONS FOR THE SIDE BETS ON
THE LIONS AND THE VIKINGS, BUT
NO.
>> GIVE US THE SUGGESTIONS.
DEFINITELY GIVE US SUGGESTIONS.
RYAN, DO YOU HAVE
A TAKE ON THE PLAY?
YOU'RE KIND OF QUIET.
>> NO DISRESPECT.
I'M ON THE LIONS TODAY, SO I
CAN'T.
I CAN'T BACK THAT.
BUT THEY CAN AND HE JUMPED IN
AND SAID BROWNS AND VIKINGS
MONEY LINE TODAY.
SO HE GOT SOME LOVE WITH THE
VIKINGS.
>> OH YEAH.
WE HAVE TO TELL THEM WHY I
PICKED THE VIKINGS.
LIKE I LITERALLY ASKED YOU THAT
QUESTION FOR A REASON.
I ASKED YOU THAT QUESTION FOR A
REASON AND SO I WANT YOU TO
KNOW.
WE CAME HERE TO PREP OR WHATEVER
AND I ASKED RYAN.
AND RYAN TOLD ME THE LIONS, THEY
WERE LOCKED TODAY.
I'M RIDING WITH THE VIKINGS
BECAUSE IT'S THE PRODUCER RUN.
>> AND WHAT ARE WE DOING, GUYS?
THEY'RE GIVING PICKS AND
ANALYSIS.
SO KEEP IT UP.
WE NEED MORE ACCOUNTS.
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE IDENTITY
THEFT AND FRAUD.
>> YEAH.
>> AND SAM, RYAN IS 4-0, BUT THE
REAL QUESTION.
HE'S 4-0.
WHAT'S THE DBOA?
>> YEAH, IT IS A FLUKE.
>> MY LUCKY FRAUD ACCORDING TO
THAT.
>> IT'S WORSE THAN THE VIKINGS.
BUT ALL RIGHT, NOW I GAVE MY
PICK.
I GAVE MY PICK.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE MR.
4-0.
MR.
PRODUCER RYAN.
AND MANY FAKE
COUNTS.
MR.
VERIFIED HIMSELF AND MR.
I NEED PLUS 2,000 OR BETTER.
NAH, I'M JUST KIDDING AND THERE
IT IS, I APPRECIATE THAT.
TAKE IT AWAY.
>> STEP INTO MY OFFICE, WE'RE
4-0.
WE'RE 4-0.
WE GOT ON THE SHOW AND THEY ARE
4-0 AND LET'S JUST LET THAT SINK
IN FOR A SECOND.
AND THEN MIKE 43 JUMPED IN AND
SAID WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THE
GIANTS AND THE EAGLES?
HE DROPPED A SECOND TAKE BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T ANSWER AND HE SAID THE
GIANTS AND THE EAGLES.
LET'S TALK.
THE NEW YORK
GIANTS, THEY MAY WIN THIS
FOOTBALL GAME TODAY.
AND I'LL SAY THAT STRAIGHT UP.
I KNOW THAT I SAID ON THE SHOW
THEY STINK, ALL OF THAT MIGHT BE
TRUE.
THEY MIGHT BE ONE OF THE WORST
TEAMS IN THE NFL.
BUT DON'T LET THE GIANTS KNOW
THAT THEY ARE HEAVY UNDERDOGS TO
A DIVISION RIVAL AT HOME.
THEY ARE PLUS 7.5
TODAY ON DRAFTKINGS.
THEY'RE GOING TO COVER THAT AND
THEY ARE GOING TO COVER IT
EASILY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE -- I KNOW
I'VE SAID WE'RE 4-0 ON THE
SHOW.
NEXT WEEK I'M GOING TO COME ON
AND SAY WE'RE 5-0.
I HAVE NOT LET YOU GUYS DOWN.
THE NEW YORK GIANTS PLUS 7.5.
IT'S A LOCK AND IT'S HITTING.
THEY MAY WIN THE GAME, BUT WE'RE
TAKING THE POINTS.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> AND THERE IT IS.
>> IF THE GIANTS HIT NEXT WEEK,
I REALLY THINK WE SHOULD INTRO
THE SHOW WHERE GREG CALLS RYAN
THE MAN, THE MYTH, THE LEGEND
AND WE START WITH RYAN'S PICKS.
I COULD JUST COMMENT ON THE BACK
END.
>> AND THAT IS ENOUGH.
I'LL ADVOCATE FOR IT.
BUT IF YOU WANT THAT, THAT'S
FAIR.
>> NO.
RYAN'S FLUKEY.
IT'S LIKE THAT
GUY.
HE'S LIKE THE
VIKINGS.
YOU NEED TO GO LIKE 7-8-0 AND
I'LL GIVE THEM CREDIT.
>> RYAN, YOU'LL BE HAPPY TO KNOW
THAT PRODUCER UNDERSCORE RYAN
SAYS I'M RIDING WITH PRODUCER
RYAN.
THERE YOU GO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I MEAN I LOVE THAT MY OWN
PRODUCER RYAN FAKE ACCOUNTS ARE
BACKING ME.
THAT WOULD BE BAD IF THEY
WEREN'T.
I LOVE THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALL RIGHT, SO WE ALL LOCKED
IN OUR PICKS.
TALK TO US.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE SAYING IN
THE CHAT?
DON'T READ, NO, I'M JUST
KIDDING.
READ THE PRODUCER RYANS AND READ
ALL THE PRODUCER RYANS.
WE LOVE THOSE.
GETTING IN THE CHAT.
HAVING SOME FUN.
>> THEY SAY IT'S THE DEATH TRAP
GAME TO STAY AWAY FOR SURE.
AND LET'S SEE, WE
NEED SOME BETS.
WE NEED SOME BETS.
BECAUSE WE WANT
TO GRADE THEM.
>> MIKE WHITE, ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN?
>> OH.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT BECAUSE
THEY WEREN'T EVEN WILLING TO
SNEAK HIM IN THE END ZONE TO WIN
THE GAME LAST WEEK AGAINST THE
VIKINGS AT ONE INCH LINE.
I'M STILL MAD ABOUT THAT.
SO NO.
DON'T LIKE IT.
>> WE HAD A TAKE FROM DR. 87
THAT SAID DEANDRE SWIFT AND THEY
WIN TODAY.
>> AND HE ALSO SAID SWIFT PLUS
MONEY LINE AND I WAS TRYING TO
GET GOOD VIBES FROM GREG.
WHAT DO WE THINK?
MINUS 110.
>> WAIT.
WHAT WAS THAT, RYAN?
I WAS READING THE COMMENTS.
I'M SORRY.
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN MINUS
110.
>> AND THAT IS NICE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN I'M ON THE OTHER SIDE.
BUT THE PICK IS COOL, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> ALL RIGHT, NOW TUA OVER 1.5
PASSING TOUCHDOWNS.
>> OVER.
DON'T HATE IT.
IT WILL BE A LOT OF POINTS IN
THAT GAME.
THE DOLPHINS WILL LOSE, BUT A
LOT OF POINTS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE LIKE IT.
>> AND KIRK COUSINS OVER 2.5
YARDS.
I'M ASSUMING THAT'S RUSHING.
I HAVE TO ASSUME THAT'S
RUSHING.
>> I WOULD SAY KIRK COUSINS OVER
2.5 PASS YARDS IS MY PLAY OF THE
DAY, SO I'LL TAKE THAT AS AN A.
>> ANTHONY PITTMAN, MARK ANDREWS
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN PLUS 240.
YOU LOVE IT.
>> YES.
I LOVE IT.
>> PLUS OR MINUS.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
NOW ANSWER ME
THAT.
WE LOVE IT.
WE COULD PUT IT IN THE PARLAY.
>> I DIDN'T SAY WE COULDN'T PUT
IT IN THE PARLAY.
YOU'RE FIGHTING YOUR OWN DEMONS,
MAN.
NO ONE SAID THAT.
>> OH MY GOD.
I DID BRING IT UP.
THE STATS, YES,
THE STATS FROM LAST YEAR.
>> THE PEOPLE CHOOSE.
>> I KNOW.
THEY BROUGHT IT UP!
THE TWO GAMES
THAT MARK ANDREWS PLAYED WITH
TYLER HUNTLEY.
IT WAS 115 YARDS AND A
TOUCHDOWN.
AND 13 RIGHT HERE.
I HAVE IT HIGHLIGHTED.
13 TARGETS, 10 RECEPTIONS, 136
YARDS AND TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
I DON'T THINK THERE WILL BE
A LOT OF POINTS IN THIS GAME
TODAY, BUT IF THEY'RE GOING TO
SCORE, IT WILL BE TYLER HUNTLEY
TO MARK ANDREWS.
THAT'S AN A PLUS PICK FOR ME.
>> YES, I AGREE.
LOZANA ASKED FOR THE RYAN
SPECIAL, SO I NEED TO GIVE THEM
THE RYAN SPECIAL.
>> THE RYAN SPECIAL.
I'M TRYING.
OKAY, HERE WE GO.
T.J.
HOCKENSON, ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN.
MARK ANDREWS, ANY TIME
AND TONY POLLARD,
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN, THAT'S THREE
LEGS.
I BELIEVE IT'S PLUS 1400.
14-1.
THAT'S HOW YOU GET RICH.
>> THERE IT IS.
RYAN, REVIEW ALL THE PICKS,
MAN.
LET'S REVIEW ALL THE PICKS FROM
TODAY BEFORE WE SAY GOOD-BYE TO
THE PEOPLE.
>> OKAY.
SO OUR ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN PARLAY, NOT THE RYAN
SPECIAL.
THE OTHER ONE THAT WILL HIT
THOUGH.
ZEKE ELLIOTT
MINUS 150.
JAMAAL WILLIAMS MINUS 120, TYLER
LOCKETT PLUS 125.
YOU PARLAY THAT.
I BELIEVE WE SAID IT WAS AROUND
PLUS 886.
OUR ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN BOOST
TODAY IS DALVIN COOK TO EVEN
MONEY PLUS 100.
THERE IT IS.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> AND THEN OUR SIX BETS WE
LOVE, WHICH WOULD BE SAM'S
PICKS.
DETROIT LIONS MONEY LINE.
CLEVELAND BROWNS PLUS 5.5.
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS PLUS 3.5.
CAROLINA PANTHERS PLUS 4.
DENVER BRONCOS PLUS 9.5.
AND THE LOS ANGELES CHARGERS
PLUS 3.5 ON SUNDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL AGAINST THE MIAMI
DOLPHINS.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> AND THEN GREG'S PICKS.
SIR, JUSTIN JEFFERSON, ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN AND THE MINNESOTA
VIKINGS TO WIN.
I WAS ON THE PAGE BEFORE, GREG,
AND YOU'LL LIKE THIS.
IT HAS NOW JUMPED TO PLUS 215.
SO WE LOVE THAT.
>> YES.
>> AND THEN MY PICK THAT WILL
NOT LOSE, THE NEW YORK GIANTS
PLUS 7.5.
AGAIN, IF YOU LIKED TO GET A
LITTLE CRAZY, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
SPRINKLE IN THE MONEY LINE
BECAUSE THEY WILL WIN, BUT WE
WILL TAKE IT EASY AND SAFE AND
TAKE THE POINTS.
SO THERE IT IS.
>> THAT'S ALL OUR PICKS.
THAT'S ALL OUR PICKS.
>> A LOT OF PICKS TODAY.
MAKE SURE YOU GET ON DRAFTKINGS
AND HELP US.
AND GUYS, IT'S TIME TO GO AND
WIN SOME MONEY.
IT'S TIME TO GET RICH.
AND SO LET'S SIGN OFF, I'M GREG
IVORY.
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN, THE MYTH,
THE LEGEND, SAM RICHMOND.
AND NEXT TO HIM IS PRODUCER
RYAN.
THE REAL PRODUCER
THE VERIFIED PRODUCER RYAN.
WE ARE OUT OF HERE.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK.
PEACE.